we want our fans and people all over the
world to really be a part of creating
the game so today we are issuing an open
invitation for people all over the world
to contribute their ideas music art
works and create original content that
players will experience as they explore
the world of the unbelievable - today is
a really really exciting day because if
you've been following me on social media
you know that I have been working on a
top-secret project I have been working
with another youtuber and fellow byung
evil fan to create a song that has the
potential to be actually played in the
game beyond good and evil - yeah crazy
but it doesn't end there you can get
involved in this song and a bunch of
other things as well I gotta explain
so you've Assaf know how long we have
been waiting for young an equal to about
12 years or something wow I'm old they
want to include their fans say thank you
and have them have pieces of themselves
and says it into a game that they adore
that they've been waiting for that is
kind of hyped right now let's be honest
so they're inviting their fans to become
a part of Beyond Good and Evil - through
many different ways and there is
literally a universe of ways for artists
to express themselves from giant
frescoes to murals street art music
radio content and much more you can get
involved right now they're using the
platform hit record which is a
collaborative platform that creates
pretty much anything just getting people
from around the world to work together
hit record is this thing I've been
making for a long long time it's really
dear to me and it's a place where people
all over the world work together on
short films or music or art all kinds of
projects is the point of hit record
it isn't just to post and promote stuff
that you've made on your own the point
is to collaborate our first creative
challenges are live as of like now and
yeah so come to our site check out the
Beyond Good and Evil 2 page at hitRECord
org and what you might get to put into
the game you get pay why am i showing
this with you because you guys send me
stuff that you make all the time be that
drawings or music you love to get
creative just as much as I do I know
when Ubisoft told me that I had a chance
to collaborate with other people on
making a song and especially that it
might even be put into the game after
it's completed I went crazy because
that's an amazing opportunity and not
only is it fun it's also something that
I'm really passionate about it's music
which I love and it's Bianca and evil
which I love it just makes sense so if I
got excited of course you guys are
getting excited you don't have to be
excited that's totally fine but if you
do want to get excited and take part
then also you could be adding to the
song that I have made with Denise now
she's all the way in America and
obviously I'm here in England so we had
to learn to work collaboratively on
other sides of the world but we came up
with what I think is a pretty awesome
song and a pretty awesome start to this
project
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
this song is not finished but it's been
put out as the first project under the
beyond good and evil section of hit
record how can you get involved in this
we're in the description below we have a
link to the hit record project where you
can view the song again and see
individual challenges that we have set
for you to help us complete this song
but I also want to share with you some
behind the scenes of how I created this
song with Denise it's a little
challenging working with people from
around the world I think the main issue
was the time difference because she
would be emailing me or messaging me
when I was asleep but it's all okay
because as long as we're both on the
same lines who kind of knew what we were
doing and we would feed each other and
keep communicating it was all good I
will share my creative process with you
it might help I don't know or you might
find interesting I don't know but this
is my creative process behind making the
unitas song oh yeah that's the song's
name by the way
number one find some inspiration trying
to force the creative process especially
when you're a writer doesn't work and
for this project I was both the writer
and the vocal artist so Denise did all
of the music which was great for me to
work from and then I would think about
what narrative we wanted to tell through
this song and also sing but first of all
I needed to get acquainted with the song
this song was created to be played in
the Ganesha City that you've seen in the
trailers and in the live streams they
wanted it to be religious to reflect on
the Hindu vibe of the city
what would the Ganesh statue so I spent
a good half a day maybe even a full day
just listening in and out to different
Hindu mantras I watched some YouTube
videos on Hinduism learnt about
reincarnation lines about reaching
enlightenment learnt about some of the
different gods actually I've got running
into it it's actually really interested
in topic rudy and lightning to see how
other people view the world basically
just educate yourself in
what you're about to create for I see
every creation as a puzzle so you kind
of have an idea in your head about the
completed puzzle but you need to make
sure that you have each of the pieces to
then create that final puzzle and
research is a massive massive part of
that what I would do while it's watching
this YouTube videos and listen to the
songs is just kind of have no but candy
wherever I was I would have a physical
notebook just jot down key words for me
to reflect on later on when I was coming
up with these lyrics
Denise then made the music which was
great because it gave me kind of a beat
to work with and a better idea of the
field that overall piece feel the beats
and the tempo see what sounds right and
then start putting some words to it from
your little key words in your notebook
which one oh yeah I like that one what
ones with that blah blah blah blah blah
I'm not making any sense um I'd
understood now a bit more about Hinduism
but I still had to come up with what do
I want this song to me so I needed to
understand the target audience we did
have a brief and in this brief it said
that it would be played for religious
officials and tourists so I knew who
were the type of people that would be
listening to this these people were more
upper-class and therefore they would be
focusing on the more positive aspects of
how they are already enlightened or how
they're reaching enlightenment through
putting their faith in the gods and from
this I came up with the it lyrics where
chosen when faith does ignite us shine
upon our freedom unite us because the
elephant God is believed to be the
remover of obstacles so therefore
freeing the citizens after I'd
understood what kind of lyrics I wanted
to be singing I then had to sing them
and then just kind of work around
understanding what kind of harmonies
might work with the initial singing they
wanted a mantra to be included in the
song so that it stayed traditional Hindu
and sticking to theme we were asked to
use the ganesh mantra this mantra was
pretty simple it's just on gam
ganapataye namaha and I think I will
remember that forever now because I've
been chanting it so so so so much but
that's the whole
point of it because that chance is
supposed to bring upon the removal of
your obstacles and anything negative in
your life so we were going to go from an
English kind of verse which I've just
told you about and then come into this
traditional mantra and when I was
listening to a lot of mantras be sung on
YouTube and things like that I noticed
there would be an initial singer but
then there would always be a group
chanting it so I wanted to recreate this
with my own voice of course you guys can
add your own voices that's actually one
of the challenges you want to add as
many different voices as possible in
loads of different pitches so please do
feel free to do that again beyond love
Denise made some wonderful low-pitched
harmonies and I played around with doing
some high-pitched harmonies were to kind
of layer on top of each other make it
seem more chance like and give it kind
of a dreamlike feel now my setup it's
it's not professional and it kind of
shows you that you don't have to have a
professional setup I mean it's great if
you do have one but um I don't even have
a pop shield and I don't have a proper
room I just use my bedroom you know
sitting in the middle of your room on
the floor actually it's supposed to get
you the best audio that's just what I've
read online so that's what I do I sit on
my yoga mat on the floor singing into my
yes you mind if I can do it then you can
do it this just shows you do not need
professional high-end equipment or setup
to get involved in any of these
challenges the premise of this whole
challenge and collaborating with other
people is just to have fun at the end of
the day and realize that you can make
something really awesome with the help
of other people because I know it's it's
difficult you make something and it's
your baby and you spent ages on it and
then for someone to add something or
change it or remix it it's easy to kind
of become way too attached to the
original version and not see it for what
it could become
but if you let go a bit and if you work
with others and if you trust them we
could get each of our own strengths put
them together and just become explosive
like the Power Rangers No shut up
okay anyway I hope this secret project
was worth waiting for you let me know in
the comments below if you're interested
in getting involved I will want to check
out what you add to this song we've got
all of our raw files over on hit record
so you can take them remix them add
stuff to them do whatever you want to do
individual challenges have more details
on how you can expand upon this song how
you can help us get it to a final piece
so do check them out with all that aside
I just want to be real with you guys for
a moment I didn't think that I would be
going to e3 this year or even next year
I remember last year thinking I I wish I
was one of those big-time youtubers that
got to go to e3 and do all these things
and maybe one day I'll be relevant and I
still don't feel relevant but I am so so
grateful for Ubisoft for reaching out to
their fans and offering them chances
like this also for coming up with
innovative ways of just incorporating
their fans creative talents into games
that they love and are passionate about
I just think it's a brush of pressure
what I just think it's a breath of fresh
air that a big company do you care about
the small people they're just as
passionate about the games that they're
making as we are they actually trusted
Denise and I to do this and keep it a
secret until the right time which is now
and and I'm just so grateful for that
but also I'm so grateful for you guys
for standing by me this whole time you
know that I have been on a journey these
last few years to try and teach myself
how to make games
understand processes behind them to find
new ways of telling stories and their
digital worlds throughout that process
sometimes I'm not around as much as
others but every time I need need some
time of way or need to focus on games
development instead of videos you're so
supportive and I can't thank you enough
for that because I am constantly trying
to bridge the gap between film and
gaming I I want to do both so badly but
sometimes I feel like I have to just
focus on one more than the other and you
get that and you let me do that and it's
so nice to have something sorry about
that
I was rambling way too much in the
camera died I don't know how to say
thank you without no rambling it's just
too too much but anyway as always same
for just want to say the matter thank
you would not be where I am today
without you guys but also I really want
you to know if you love something you're
passionate about it makes you happy keep
doing it if it's bringing you happiness
that's what means the most thank you
again
every day or evening bye
[Music]
[ __ ]